community members can give back to
families in need all month long it's
part of the clothes for Comfort campaign
a donation effort for the less fortunate
as well as abused and neglected kids
here in our area we join Laura negretti
this morning from the Clark County
Government Center to talk a little bit
more about it and and we're we're who
it's really going to benefit and help
Lauren good morning
exactly good morning yes there's a bunch
of things already here in this big
donation box here we've got some clothes
and some shirts and some jeans of course
we're going to get cold in the warmer
months we'll need some shorts here too
but I'm joined with Marilyn Kirkpatrick
Clark County Commissioner who really you
really started this champion this three
years ago let's talk about here what is
most needed during this month of
donations so really um we always like
brand new socks and undergarments for
our young men and women so any of those
that you may have or you pick up at a
store gladly take those but close as a
whole are important and it's such a
prime time when spring cleaning is going
on and kids are growing out of things to
senior gently used stuff because they'll
go to a good cause exactly and speaking
about that good cause that's a little
better understanding of what the harbor
is so the harbor really is a something
that we're proud of at Clark County it
was established in 2016 for our Juvenile
Diversion program so kids were referred
by their counselors or police agencies
and so rather than get them into our
system we wanted to help them get back
on track but we quickly realized that
the whole family needs resources great
and it's such a great resource and this
is too again you could donate all this
month and afterwards too but big
championship for this month here we're
going to have all those details for you
on our website 8newsnow.com for now live
at the Clark Government Center Laura
negretti 8 News Now